kaley cuoco is not shy about her
bachelor fandoms check out those
leggings she weighed in on vens final
decision with ET totally love Lauren B
and think it was a great choice there
obviously an extremely unattractive
couple which is very sad for them
hideously ugly so that they don't have
that going for them but yes I we were
very excited it was really great finale
typically on the bachelor bachelorette
they have celebrities come in and kind
of help plan some dates would you ever
be interested in doing that oh I don't
know if they want me to plan a date I'd
be like just sit on the couch order some
takeout
turn on The Bachelor I'd want them to
watch themselves they just wouldn't it
wouldn't be something they'd want to do
that's your ideal night yes yes it is
Haley and the Big Bang cast stepped out
for PaleyFest coming up on the show
Bernadette is having a baby
they'll likely cast twins to play the
part are you excited to be working with
some twins no I'm not so I really twins
really oh they have to get jhula the
balls right oh god maybe she can be
pregnant for like three seasons so we
can wait like a couple years yeah you
know we'll see I just no dogs no babies
that's my rule at home but not on set
not at work separate Britt